okay thanks um again echoing all the
speakers thanks to meredith for putting
together a great program
um with ideas that have been very
important to me and i think to our whole
field
for a very long time um this talk
dovetails very nicely with the last one
um just as daniel started with i think i
want to start with noting a commonality
between this idea of citing how the
brain has internal models
and this research program which has been
extremely influential in both
neuroscience and cognitive science
over the last couple of decades this
idea that we can understand
a sort of a unifying paradigm for
intelligence in many systems
using the tools of probability theory
decision theory putting those together
this the basic kind of mathematical
currency of intelligence of
probabilities and utilities
this has been influential in models of
single organisms both humans and other
species
it's also been useful in models of
social intelligence like trying to
understand collective
agency and also trying to model other
kinds of intelligence systems in biology
like for example
the process of sensing a decision making
in single cells i think there is a sense
in which a human brain the brain of
other mammals other species
with nervous systems something like ours
maybe even a society
and even you know say a yeast single
cell or population
all of them in some form build internal
models of their environment
using in some ways or a way we can
describe at least in some ways
mathematically
with these tools it's not just on the
biological sciences but on engineering
right and part of what i do is try to
make a bridge between
the sort of reverse engineering of the
brain and engineering more human-like ai
systems
and these same tools have been extremely
useful in building a whole range of ai
technologies which i think everybody
here is familiar with
things like you know not only google but
say self-driving cars question answering
systems
systems for finding pedestrians
recognizing faces
any one of these would have impressed
the early founders of ai
yet i think something really important
is missing the most important thing
none of these systems are truly
intelligent we still don't have ai
although we have these impressive ai
technologies
and though we have these unifying
mathematical ideas for understanding
intelligence
we still don't have actually adequate
models that can take the inputs coming
into your brain
and produce the actual outputs that your
brain does in behavior
except you know in in sort of very
simple uh laboratory tasks
but i think building unifying models
that actually can account for the way
you know any of our brains are
functioning right now still eludes us
and there's many reasons for this but i
think one is that we haven't grappled
with
the the heart of what the internal
models uh at least for
the human brain and i'd say at least
some of the smarter animal species
um what their internal models are really
like so i want to give a bit of a
historical perspective here
from the work of ken craig how many
people have heard of craig
okay he's not quite as well known as he
should be he's not as well known as his
contemporary alan turing
like turing he was a brilliant young
british mathematician physicist sort
spent a lot of time around cambridge
also died tragically early for different
reasons
but he wrote one really important book
which i think set the agenda for at
least the cognitive sciences
in internal models it's called the
nature of explanation and i think he got
right to the heart of the matter of what
these internal models in human cognition
were about
and raised the challenge even before we
barely under had any scientific
understanding of neural circuits
of how this might work in the brain so
let's just reflect on this here
one of the most fundamental properties
of thought is its power of predicting
events
it enables us for instance to design
bridges with a sufficient factor of
safety instead of building them
haphazard and waiting to see whether
they collapse
if the organism and he's again he's
talking about all organisms here
but this is you know for me at least i'm
thinking about the human organism
if the organism carries a small scale
model of external reality
and of its own possible actions within
its head it is able to try out various
alternatives
conclude which is the best of them react
to future situations before they arise
utilize the knowledge of past events in
dealing with the present and future
and in every way to react in a much
fuller safer and more competent manner
to the emergencies which face it
much of the greatest advances of modern
technology have been instruments
which extended the scope of our sense
organs our brains or our limbs
such are telescopes and microscopes
wireless calculating machines
typewriters motor cars ships and
airplanes notice he doesn't mention
computers because they didn't have any
and yet i think he was still able to
conceive of i think the
one of the deepest ideas i know of of
what computation actually is
in the human brain is it not possible
therefore that our brains themselves
utilize comparable mechanisms
to achieve the same ends and that these
mechanisms can parallel phenomena in the
external world as a calculating machine
can parallel the development of strains
in a bridge
this is i think what we really need to
get at here and it means taking these
ideas of probabilities and utilities but
adding something to the mix and that's
what i want to talk about in this
research program where now if what we're
getting at here is really the heart i
think of human common sense
and it's a very big problem so in order
to approach it you need to have some
idea of sort of where to start and how
to approach and so i mostly want to try
to give you the sense of how we've been
doing that in our group in the last few
years
it's sort of a what and a how the what
is what i like to call the common sense
core and it's an idea that's not my idea
it comes from many people
it's i'd say more than anything it comes
from developmental psychologists
like liz spelke renee baerjan uh others
mentioned on here
and it's this idea that from the very
beginning in some form
human thought is structured around a
basic understanding
of the physical world and the social
world physical objects intentional
agents and their causal interactions
these are kinds of intuitive theories of
physics intuitive theories of psychology
with notions of forces and masses to
them
notions of desires beliefs plans and so
on
and it's this is this is the you know
out of all the kinds of mental
simulations of the world that say craig
could have been talking about
this is i think where to start these
concepts are present in some form as
early as you can look in human infants
and then and you sort of develop in in
rich ways over the first year of life
they're transformed uh as uh a child
acquires language
but they're also shared in some
important non-linguistic ways with many
other species and i think that's why
they're also a good target for
neuroscience
they are not um simply about vision or
language or action but they're kind of
the nexus of where all these things come
together
i think it's the basic building blocks
of visual scene understanding
it's the it's the basic building blocks
of meaning and language
and it's the targets of action planning
so the research program here is to try
to reverse engineer this common sense
core
and the two questions i'll mostly try to
convey to you today here are ways we're
beginning to try to answer these
questions at least
is how can these kinds of core internal
models be understood computationally and
studied quantitatively with a kind of
psychophysics of common sense
now bigger harder questions are how
might these kind of internal models be
instantiated in neural circuits and how
might they be built
and i'm not just saying learned but
built over a combination of adaptive
processes on different time scales
including evolutionary
developmental and learning like the
kinds of things that daniel was talking
about before
these the last questions are things
we're just beginning to get at maybe if
there's time i'll gesture towards those
at the end
i want to focus on the first two
questions so just to make this a little
bit more concrete
the kinds of things we're interested in
studying are are these here the ones on
the left are sort of the intuitive
physics
in visual scenes and the ones on the
right more the intuitive psychology
so we want to know when you look at a
scene like this how are you able to not
just do as say david maher famously said
figure out what is where but figure out
all the physics of the scene
what's supporting what what's attached
to what what would happen if say the
table is bumped
what would fall off what's kind of
perched precariously on the side
all those kinds of things or like in
this scene here
with this construction scene of a house
you don't have to know anything about
house building i
certainly don't to know that some of
these pieces of wood are probably more
structurally important than others
some could be removed more safely some
some are not attached to anything and
you could just walk off with them if
if you were so inclined or this scene
from our local cafe over across the
street area four that the barista
described as a
kind of disaster in waiting right you
know that these coffee dishes
uh stacked up here you can't just pick
up the dish from this handle here and
walk away with these and bust them
you have to restack these otherwise
there's going to be a you know a big
mess
okay or in these scenes here right you
identify the people
but also you get inside their heads you
get some idea of what their relationship
is to each other
what they want from each other what
their desires are what they think about
each other
i mean look at this scene here this
crossing guard scene right and think
about
what's going on inside the mind of this
crossing guard here
um the mental states she's tracking both
of the people who she's not facing but
who she knows are there the kids and the
other teachers
who's she looking at here when she's
holding up the stop sign making eye
contact presumably with a driver
and it's it's you know we we talk a lot
about theory of mind and that's one
interesting place where
i think we have internal models but it's
this kind of nonverbal implicit theory
of mind
that we're really trying to get at which
in some form as developmental
psychologists have shown
is present as early as you can look what
i'll mostly talk about are
behavioral tasks with adults a little
bit about babies if there's time
but it's really trying to get at this
kind of common sense here what what's
going on when kids are playing with
blocks
playing with each other playing with it
with each other playing with blocks and
so on
so that's the what what about the how
and here the basic idea is to try to
really get at what i think craig was
talking about the idea of the brain as a
very flexible modeling engine using the
computational tools
of what are called probabilistic
programs now i don't have time to tell
you really any technical details i'll
just try to give you a pic
flavor of this and the gate the title of
the talk the game engine in your head
is i think the most concrete way i can
try to illustrate this
if you want more technical details i
would i would suggest that you go to the
webpage promods.org
which is a website that's mostly
maintained by noah goodman i also
contributed to it
noah goodman who used to be here in our
group and is now a professor at stanford
along with vikash mansinga dan roy and a
number of others who were in our group
and have now gone off in different
directions
they developed the main technical
material that's really the theoretical
heart of what i'm going to be talking
about here this idea of probabilistic
programs
the probabilistic programs are in some
form very similar to bayesian networks
so how many people have heard of
bayesian networks okay so this is this
is a computationally
very appealing way to take the ideas
that say daniel talked about and several
of the other speakers
sort of build a very general toolkit for
building
internal causal models right these are
these are all
in some form causal models and they're
probabilistic models and what makes them
appealing
is two things they are general purpose
languages for describing causal models
of the world
anything that you can describe with a
directed graph nodes and arrows
where the nodes represent some things
you can measure in the world or think
about some random variables and the
arrows represent the causal links
anything that like that that you can
describe with a graph you can put
probabilities on and start to do
you know reasoning under uncertainty
inference from sparse data even optimal
decisions
and there are general purpose algorithms
we have general purpose languages for
representation and general purpose
algorithms for doing inference and
decision and learning on these models
but the problem is they're not enough i
don't think they can capture what's
going on in the scenes that i was
talking about they don't capture
even the core common sense physics and
models of other agents
that we see even in young children what
we need is something
that's in a sense goes beyond the graphs
it's the problem is with the graphs
right or the networks and this is also
what's going to pose
the real challenge for bridging to the
neural circuit level right because
there's something appealing about the
idea of a network you know we have
bayesian networks neural networks maybe
they're kind of the same maybe we can
take these general purpose algorithms
and relate them to general purpose
principles of neural processing
and there's been some really interesting
work doing that but part of what i want
to do here is raise a challenge for that
because i think fundamentally
graphs are just not rich enough to
capture the causal processes that our
common sense
is working with and it's not just common
sense but think about science
right it's very very much um akin to
this crake idea of the mind as a
model builder is the idea that in many
ways cognition in adults and even young
children is a kind of like intuitive
theory building you might have heard of
the theory theory for example and think
about the structure of scientific
theories either early modern ones like
newton's gravitation or mendel's
genetics
or more modern theories right like for
example
all the things that are shown here and
the way the the laws of the theory its
fundamental concepts
in in almost no case are they captured
as a graph right there are some models
in for example biology we talk about you
know protein protein interaction
networks
genetic networks there are some places
where our causal models of the world
fit into the language of graphs but you
know in many cases they're like
equations
or i'd say more generally programs right
so for example if we want to build a
model
of um or express a theory of how rivers
are formed like this one here which if i
can click on i can
make you a nice movie animation right so
this is this is a
sort of a geological model of riverbed
formation or think about fluid mechanics
or climate modeling or aerodynamics or
this is example from a simulation of
galaxies colliding right
in almost all cases the theory is one
which where you express the causal
processes
in terms of abstract laws which in the
if they're very very simple if they're
simple enough like newton's laws
and you only have say two bodies you can
solve them analytically
right you can solve for the the fact
that the orbits of the planets are
ellipses as
they go around the sun um but in almost
all cases
the the the fundamental causal laws are
too too complex to solve analytically
yet by writing them as programs you can
simulate them you can simulate them
in on large scale on a you know a modern
machine
or if you're mendel you know you can
write down a simple kind of
probabilistic program of how
genes give rise to phenotypes and genes
are transmitted across generations and
sort of
simulate them kind of on pencil and
paper but the basic idea is the same
and the particular kind of programs that
we're going to be
be embedding in our probabilistic models
are inspired by
game engines how many people know what a
game engine is okay
um people don't know what a game engine
is all right um so we're about half and
half so game engines are very general
pieces of software
that have been developed so that a lot
more people could write video games than
otherwise
um it turns out you know many video
games particularly that want the kinds
of ones shown here these sort of
first person 3d immersive experiences
right there's a lot of stuff that if you
want to write one of these games
that you don't really want to have to
write from scratch every time
things like how graphics renderers work
right to give a rich sense of immersion
in a virtual world
or physics engines right in order to say
model what's going to happen when
uh you know a car collides with a wall
or a rocket-propelled grenade collides
with a wall or
a person collides with a yeah they're
sort of violent but
um or you know how probably people have
played games like angry birds
i guess that's kind of violent at least
to to the birds um
or other kinds of physics touch screen
games that are very popular even with
young kids right like stack up the
blocks cut the rope fill the water and
so on
so this these are the kinds of things
we're doing we're building models of
intuitive
physics and visual scenes using those
physics engines
and graphics engines to capture sort of
the vision part of the problem
where you think of some underlying world
state like like say the
three-dimensional objects in the world
as being not directly observed that's
why it's gray here
but via some kind something like a
graphics process
uh again to kind of go back to an old
theme if you know sort of helmholtz's
idea of vision is inverse optics and
many people have talked about vision as
a kind of inverse graphics that's that's
part of this picture
i think it's it's our it's the first way
into these internal models
where you observe the images that are
the outputs of a graphics rendering
program effectively
and you want to work backwards to make
some kind of a guess of what the input
to the graphics program is that's a way
to think about vision
and then you want to be able to take
that world state that you've inferred by
somehow kind of guessing the input to
your graphics program
from the observed output and running it
forwards or backwards to imagine what's
going to happen next
or what what happened in the recent past
and similarly kind of
other kinds of programs like planning
programs which are also in game engines
right
these are very simple kind of agent
models that often underlie the
the game ai not the not the player but
the sort of non-player characters like
the guards of the base or the zombies or
something
simple programs which have some notion
of belief and desire very very simple
ones
and then produce sequences of actions
which achieve the desires giving the
beliefs
um since this since time is short i
probably will mostly focus on the
physics side of things maybe show one
slide on the uh
intuitive psychology um but just to give
the scope of what we're trying to get at
here
okay so this is one part of the
technical know-how behind the site this
work it's the representation since this
idea that we take the kinds of
rich programs for modeling physics of
the world graphics
planning embed them inside a
probabilistic inference framework a
framework of bayesian inference and
decision theory the same
one that we started off with and i think
many people here have found
extremely useful in their work and then
we use that to model the
heart of these sort of common sense
model building now there's also a lot of
work on algorithms for
for inference right remember i said with
bayesian networks what made them
successful
was a general purpose representation
language that's the graphs which we've
now turned into programs
and then general purpose algorithms
where you just take a graph
and you observe let's say you know the
output of any of these variables and you
sort of just press a button and suddenly
some efficient algorithm makes good
guesses about the values of the
variables you didn't observe
right and there are also learning
algorithms parameter and structure
learning algorithms like daniel was
talking about
and i i will have almost nothing to say
about the algorithms
that make inference work in these
probabilistic programs except for a few
things about simulation
and other other kinds of algorithms
which i'll show you in a bit that
actually
might have some neural plausibility to
them or at least give us some places to
look for where
inference and probabilistic programs
might be working in the brain
but mostly what i want to do is just
give you a couple of case studies again
mostly on the physics side here
and i'm going to start with vision very
much paralleling daniel
i don't really think of myself as a
vision person i'm a little out of my
comfort zone
but some people in our group have
recently been doing some very exciting
work
even connecting here to faces how eerily
parallel
where i just think it's a really nice
way to see these ideas
in action and study them and also relate
to the brain
um so you know this is this is an
example of a system that's a few years
old that's been instantiated
in in cars that you can buy that detect
objects detect uh other cars detect
pedestrians
we're all familiar with face detection
systems in our digital cameras and
online and so on
and you know this is again one of these
great ai technologies but the problem of
actually say detecting people or
recognizing faces
as our brains solve it is much harder
than what uh
currently works in the state of the art
and though you'll often hear about
problems like these as being solved
they're solved in certain limited
domains like the domain that
the way people typically look to a car
when your car's about to hit them
that's a very characteristic thing and
with millions of training examples a
neural network can be trained to
identify just those people but think
about how you detect the people say in
this scene
okay so this is a bunch of people the
bunch of computer vision researchers in
particular
um on on a commuter airplane to a
computer vision conference
and think about all the people that you
can detect here right i mean you can you
can
just count them up in your head you know
and most of these people only occupy a
few pixels in the image and most of
their bodies are invisible
right they're occluded but and not only
do you know they're there you can also
say where they are like
you know for example for this guy here
you have a pretty good idea of where his
right hand is right here how about this
so here's a guy
and i'll just move my blazer pointer and
you hum when you think i'm somewhere
near his right hand
okay
okay so there's a cheap experiment but
yeah you basically it's all
yeah how did you do that right okay so
there's a posterior predictive
probability distribution i want to know
what's the mental model in your head
that allows you to compute that
or to take a face recognition problem
here um
this is a postdoc in our lab ilker
yildirim who's been doing some of this
work
um and you can see him i took a sort of
bad picture of him now how about this
who's this
yeah well you can't really tell but it
is actually that's also ilker
yeah um and uh you'd be forgiven for
for not knowing but it's it's certainly
plausible and many of you recognize it
as the same person
even really really impressive face
recognition technologies right now
that places like facebook and google are
putting out uh have trouble with this
kind of thing but you you don't have
trouble
with it not nearly as much as those
systems and we think this is because
again of the kind of internal models
that your brain builds
of what's going on here models like
these so here's an example of a program
that was built by tejas kulkarni who's a
grad student in our group to solve this
kind of problem and it's an example of
taking probabilistic programs building
in particular probabilistic
graphics programs which are the kinds of
tools that that people in computer
graphics would use to make realistic
imagery of faces
and then by embedding them in a
probabilistic inference framework being
able to condition their outputs on an
observed image and effectively kind of
run them backwards
to understand the sort of rich scene
that gave rise to the image of a face
so in this case the particular
probabilistic uh sort of graphics model
we're using was developed by others it
was developed by thomas vetter's group
now called the basal face model from
basil switzerland
and this is it has basically a sort of
high dimensional representation
of the 3d shape of a face and its parts
as well as the texture like the facial
appearance
and then there's also sort of
traditional kinds of graphics parameters
like modeling the lighting direction and
there's a shading model in here
and there's a kind of affine camera
angle pose variable
those pink things those are all the
unobserved inputs to the program what we
observe is the output
so these are a bunch of sort of random
outputs of this program by
randomly choosing these these inputs and
seeing what
the face looks like these are sort of
fantasies from the generative model if
you like
now doing bayesian perception here
bayesian inverse graphics is something
like this
you observe this guy's face and then you
want to hypothesize
random scenes that that when you sort of
image them under through this rendering
pipeline
look something like that like the
observed person so for example
this here is the synthesized output from
our graphics engine
that after a little bit of inference the
system decides looks kind of enough like
that guy to to
perceive what's going on now again it
doesn't look exactly like that guy
and it doesn't match down to the pixel
level part of what's important in
making these things work is coming up
with kind of clever ways in some cases
to match observed images to these
synthesized samples from your internal
model
that might involve various kinds of
features for example the outputs of
these deep convolutional neural networks
which you know again have revolutionized
a lot of applied computer vision
here that's not the heart of what we're
doing but that and many other ways of
building useful feature representations
might be a good way for example to
quickly match
the the observed image to a sample from
an internal model
just to show you a little bit of this
kind of system running here
so here's an observed image and here's
the system doing a kind of
markov chain monte carlo inference
trying to match the observed image by
by exploring in a random but sort of
usefully biased way
this this the internal parameters of
this graphics model and you can see the
result isn't perfect but it's reasonably
good
now having having built this it's not
just the point isn't just to
match an image right but you now have an
internal model of the face
that for example you can imagine what
that face would look like from other
angles right so these are three observed
images and these are examples of having
fit the model to that person's face
then re-rendering under very different
poses and lighting conditions
this is a kind of you know imagery
dreaming of conditional dreaming
but it underlies this model's ability to
do a much harder kind of
same different facial identity task than
a lot of even really good machine
sort of more machine learning based face
recognition systems can do and i won't
tell you the details of this but we
basically
will sho you know show people an image
uh of a face
under very severe pose and lighting
variations
and people can still be pretty correct
uh with just you know
brief presentation maybe just say 500
milliseconds maybe even closer to 100
milliseconds in some cases
um being able to say whether it's the
same person or a different person
and this model is able is able to
actually do pretty well in matching
behavior there
just to show that it's not just about
faces we can do the same kind of thing
with an internal model of a body
so here the graphics engine is just
basically an articulated body model the
same kind of thing that you know you
might plausibly have
in some of the motor systems uh models
that that we saw earlier today
here's an example of taking an observed
image of this guy
i think it's usain bolt and sort of
again exploring in this
internal model um and re-rendering what
it might look like until you've roughly
matched that
image okay now hopefully as you've seen
there's some fairly impressive results
that come from this
it's also rather slow i showed you a
couple of movies to make that point
right
we don't think perception is this slow
and one of the things that we've been
working on and this is ilker's work
ilker yildirim together with tejas is
looking at various ways to build
approximate recognition models much
faster ways of inverting these
probabilistic programs
and this is just one i'm trying to show
you a few different ways that you might
do
inference and probabilistic programs in
vaguely brain like ways i think the idea
of stochastic sampling
that i was just showing is is two is
sort of
you know many people have proposed some
neurally plausible variant of that
i think it's too slow for what is mostly
a bottom-up perception process like a
face perception and body
pose identification and something like
this is another neurally plausible
mechanism
which is based on a really interesting
idea of jeff hintons from the mid-90s
what was called the
helmholtz machine or the wake sleep
algorithm how many people have heard of
that
how many people have not heard of that
okay um good
i'm happy to see how many people have
heard of it okay um
so um the wake sleep algorithm i will
again i can't go into the details but it
was basically the idea of
taking a a rich interestingly structured
well or not so interestingly structure
but having some generative model
and being able to learn a recognition
model which is basically a neural
network that whose arrows go in the
other direction
by drawing samples from the generative
model much like the random samples i've
shown you which provide
a very rich and extensive source of
label data for training the bottom-up
recognition model
in a way that you know in our natural
experience we don't get nearly so much
labeled data so it's a kind of
self-supervised
learning what you're doing is you're not
the learning here is learning to do
inference really quickly it doesn't
actually
in this case change the generative model
but allows you to learn
a neural network a kind of a
convolutional network recognition model
that dramatically speeds up inference
and gets it into the realm of something
that's kind of neurally plausible
so this is just the red curve here is
just basically the speed of inference
this is some kind of accuracy measure as
a function of time
for the sort of the kind of top-down
monte carlo
mcmc approach i showed you and the blue
curve is what's what you get from this
bottom-up recognition model using this
to initialize inference and then doing a
little bit of cleanup
uh iteration on the mcmc side and you
can see that you get most of the way
very very quickly and then you clean it
up a little bit i think that starts to
be sort of a plausible way
to get it the way many neuroscientists
who are say studying visual recognition
think that think about the interaction
between bottom-up and top-down
processing
and this model although i can't tell you
any of the details
is even able it's part of why we're
studying faces to actually make some
pretty interesting sense
of these very interesting neural
circuits for the face patch system
that vin rick freewald who's one of our
collaborators in this project has
studied with doris sao and i think many
of you are familiar with
if you're interested in that you might
have seen ilker's poster earlier on
and i can tell you more about that later
what i want to do for my remaining
few minutes is just get what i think is
some of the more interesting kinds of
internal models that are not just about
vision but more about thinking so like
this idea of intuitive physics that i
referred to before
so we've been doing a whole bunch of
experiments that started with work that
peter battaglia has done in our lab he's
now
a researcher at deepmind google and jess
hamrick who's now a phd student at uc
berkeley
and you know again we basically were
setting up experiments in our lab
to have people studying or making
inferences like kids playing with blocks
this is actually inspired by the jenga
game how many people have played
jenga okay okay i'm glad to see that
jenga is the most popular thing i've
asked about so far
so we show people these these various
stacks of wooden blocks or simulated
wooden blocks
and we ask ask you to judge how stable
they are under gravity so these are like
freeze frames and we say if we turn on
gravity
how likely is one of these towers to
fall and hopefully even if you haven't
played jenga you get the sense that the
ones over here are pretty stable
the ones over here very likely to fall
under gravity how do we model this as a
kind of a probabilistic program
well here's here's an elaboration of
what i showed you before
where you've got some underlying world
state you've got some observed images at
various points in time here i'm showing
you one observed image
we view that image again as the output
of a graphics program and just as i
showed you with faces or bodies
you can make a hypothesis about the
underlying three-dimensional scene in
the world that would give rise to that
image you know maybe something like that
again i'm just
rendering it here in a kind of cad model
but it's actually a 3d model
which you can then give as the input to
a physics engine and run a sort of a
very coarse approximate
uh model of some aspects of newtonian
mechanics again it's one of the same
kind of physics engine used in a lot of
game physics
run this forward a few time steps and
just kind of see what happens this is
your
internal model and what you see is that
you know the blocks sort of fall over a
little bit now
that's one sample in this probabilistic
inference model
here's another sample with a different
uh sample inverting
the the image getting the 3d state and
and running it forward again a few time
steps and you can see these are somewhat
different right
the actual state of the world comes out
a little bit different the actual way it
runs forward comes out a little bit
different and there's various sources of
internal noise which we've tried to
model and study here
but in the end you know basically the
same thing happens right either you get
something like that or something like
that namely most of the box blocks fall
over
so if you just run a few samples like
that you can make a pretty good guess at
what's going to happen
and then in our experiments we compare
the guesses of a few samples in this
kind of a model
to the guesses of a group of subjects
and here i'm just showing you
what that looks like for one experiment
where we gave people 60 towers of this
form
each of these dots here each plus the
the vertical and horizontal little lines
here are the error bars
represents one tower stimulus on the
y-axis we're plotting the average
judgment of people on a one-to-seven
scale you can do the same with the two
afc design and get
similar outputs where up on the top
means the tower is very likely to fall
under gravity according to people
on the bottom very unlikely to fall and
what you see here is is what the model
predicts and you can see
that basically it does a pretty good job
of predicting what people will say here
now we can build similar kinds of models
for in the sort of
core theory of mind domain but since
time is short i'm not going to go into
it but
i'll just say we can get even in some
sense even more quantitatively
predictive psychophysical models now
making modeling people's judgments about
beliefs and desires
what i just want to do in the time that
i have left is talk about
again going back to this idea of the the
crate idea
this you know more than 50 year old idea
of the mind as a flexible
uh internal model builder it's sort of
the same idea behind the turing test
right it's the flexibility
of human cognition that we really want
to get at and for any one of these
domains like the block world domain
we're studying here
there's an endless number of questions
that you can ask by querying this
internal model
so for example we can show you the same
kinds of towers but tell you that say
one color is 10 times heavier than the
other
that will change whether you think
they're going to fall over or which way
you think they'll fall in ways that you
know people systematically respond to
and the model can capture
or we cannot tell you which one is
heavier but just show you some scenes
like these ones here
which might be a little implausibly
stable like take this scene here
and say okay now this looks like
probably to most of you it should fall
over but suppose i tell you know this is
actually
static it's not moving um but i tell you
that might seem funny but i tell you one
color
is 10 times heavier than the other which
color do you think is the heavy color
here
yeah okay right it's a little bit harder
uh
rebecca said red is right this is a
little harder because you have to do a
couple of different rounds of simulation
that's again that's the sort of thing
which we could actually try to map onto
the dynamics and behavior or in the
brain um
to to to to take us all a little bit
outside of our comfort zone because you
could say well
we've all you know played with blocks
since um we were very young children
that's sort of the point
uh going back to the very much the same
question that daniel was getting at you
know
do we really have internal models that
we can run and simulate like this or do
we have we just
learned from experience how to solve
particular tasks
you could say all the tasks i've shown
you so far with these intuitive physics
are things that you've
you've done a lot before but unless
you've seen me talk about this stuff you
probably haven't done
this task so in this task i've got a
bunch of red and yellow blocks on the
table
and i want you to imagine that i bump
the table hard enough to knock some of
the blocks onto the floor
is it more red or yellow blocks what do
you say red or yellow
yeah okay
i know it's late let's do not just
rebecca
yeah we can keep going all day right i
mean that's the point we could we could
literally keep going all day now how
could you do that
i mean if you've ever done that before
unless you're doing something like what
our model is doing i'll just show you
this is an example of running one of
these simulations simulating a sort of a
small bump
and you see you know all the yellow
blocks go over here's a big bump
um again you know different totally
different thing happens except basically
the same thing happens right
if this is the way you do a kind of uh
intuitive statistics you only need to do
one or a few of those simulations
to get the idea that most of the yellow
blocks are going to go over
and this kind of model which is the same
model i've been showing you before we're
just doing different things with it
um can quantitatively predict people's
judgments on this task and we could just
keep pushing it we can change the sizes
and shapes of the blocks
and again the same model basically
predicts we can tell you which direction
the force comes from that's the blue
dots
or we cannot tell you still works right
we can use this and i think this is the
kind of thing that might be of great
interest to many people here although
we've only just started to do this so i
can't tell you the results yet too much
but we can use this model to actually
guide action planning so here we have
people trying to construct
stable towers most of these look like
they should fall over but you get glue
and you're playing a very fun game
where you basically have to use the
minimal amount of glue you can to make
this thing stand up
and we've been able to show how this
kind of model can
this in pilot data can account for how
people plan in these tasks
in some recent work that we've been
doing in our lab that chris bates has
been doing along with ilker and
pete battaglia we've been extending this
to various kinds of non-rigid surfaces
and fluids
so you know we think your internal
physics engine is not simply about
blocks
just as the world we can also extend
these kind of models to dynamics so
here's one more
sort of live action demo i'm here
imagine we're watching a ball bouncing
around an air hockey table or a billiard
table from the top
and it's going to bounce off the walls
that the blue it's the blue ball it can
bounce off the black
obstacles and then you've got these red
and green patches on the floor of the
table and you have to respond
whether it's let's say red or green or
we'll just say ooh or ah
according to whether you think the ball
is more likely to hit the red one first
or the green one first and
you might have to predict far into the
future again this is a key part of our
internal models as a number of the other
speakers have emphasized
so we'll just watch this movie and you
just say ooh
if you think it's going to hit the red
one first or ah if you think it's going
to hit the green one first
okay ready here we go
yeah so notice how you could predict
at least those of you who are awake um
you could predict the the green
one a couple of bounces in advance and
that's sort of typical we can
model this as a kind of sort of dynamic
evidence accumulation process so here
i'm just running this thing forward and
you can see this is the the model's
predictions it's very much of a kind of
sort of
shadlin-like evidence accumulation model
it's not it hasn't been studied in
neurons but again we think
this kind of thing could plausibly be
studied in neurodynamics and it supports
very
very quantitative psychophysics which
again this is just
four of a number of different trials
that we've where we've compared the
model to human behavior
i think it's one place where we can take
the kind of internal models
that we've been studying in human
cognition and
bring it into a setting where it'd be
interesting for neuroscience um
we it with some of our collaborators uh
in particular erno teglis and luca
benatti the same kind of ability to
predict just dots bouncing around things
uh which uh i should probably not dwell
on too much
this is the kind of stimulus you show to
a young baby can predict a baby's
uh predictions based on their looking
time their violations of expectation
and just to again sort of bring this
back to the brain and then i'll stop
since i think i'm
50 seconds over this is not my work but
this is some very exciting work in nancy
cammisscher's lab by jason fisher
where he's taken a range of tasks
including some of the kinds of ones that
i've shown you
some tasks which are like these also
kind of dot prediction tasks like the
ones i just showed you briefly
and compared for example physical and
social scenes with the same kind of
simple stimuli
or compared physical and non-physical
tasks with the tower stimuli
and found some very intriguing results
which are still being written up for
publication but please ask jason about
it
suggesting that there are circuits in
pre-motor and parietal
areas which across a number of different
tasks consistently seem to respond
like what you'd expect a physics engine
to do so we think that these kinds of
ideas are
things we can study in you know
computational models with a lot of
quantitative psychophysics
and that they might actually be we might
actually be able to study them
as brain systems there are even some
people in the neural network modeling
community who are actually building
kind of computational neural circuit
type models very abstractly
that can try to capture some of this but
i think really mapping these ideas
to neural circuits is a huge open
challenge and learning is such an open
challenge that i'll actually skip it and
conclude
so what i've tried to argue is that if
we want to get at the idea of internal
models in human cognition
going back to craig but also very much
influenced by a lot of recent work in
developmental psychology which studies
the roots of common sense
in young infants young children has
identified correlates of all these
things but also looking to our
neuroscience colleagues
who you know as nancy has been doing
there with jason as rebecca is well
known for doing in theory of mind
suggests that there's a real core of
common sense around intuitive physics
and intuitive psychology
and then i think if we target our
reverse engineering efforts on these
systems these kinds of internal models i
think we will really make fundamental
advances in our field now i've tried
here what i've tried to show is this
idea technically of probabilistic
programs
how this can start to sort of answer
model these
these problems model these kinds of
knowledge systems
computationally support quantitative
psychophysics but i hope you also can
see that there are
really huge challenges the most
interesting ones specifically for
engaging with
with more of the neural circuit level
remain open so i hope some of you are
inspired to work on these kinds of
things and
join us in this effort thank you